when you think of a Wes Anderson film
you probably immediately think of the
visual elements of his style cemetry
intricate set design long tracking shots
and vibrant color palettes all stand out
as big pieces of what makes a Wes
Anderson movie look like a Wes Anderson
movie but for Wes Anderson there was a
time before all those stereotypically
Wes Anderson things existed Anderson's
first film bottle rocket looks for lack
of a better word more or less like a
normal movie but even if bottle rocket
doesn't have the look we've come to
associate with Anderson's films it still
feels like an Anderson movie and our
tour directors first film will often
contain themes ideas and stylistic cues
that will reoccur in their later work
and bottle rocket is an excellent
example of this many elements of wes's
style already exist in bottle rocket
just in a more subtle way let's look
through the film for those themes ideas
and elements of style that he would
reuse and develop throughout his
filmography thanks to movie for
sponsoring this video go to movie comm
slash Thomas flight for your extended
free trial number one dialog one day
walk so he says Dignan you're out just
like that
by the way man he was right it's just
cuz it's a front doesn't mean somebody
doesn't after the actual landscaping how
did she die by the way your mother may I
officiate by the way the ceremony when
was the last time you were in America by
the way you know a year don't worry I've
been stealing birds for a living since
before I could drop by the way you look
unbelievably beautiful tonight you're
practically glowing how much you worth
by the way I don't know over 10 million
it's difficult to describe the mixture
of deadpan delivery of ridiculous lines
comical delivery of serious lines
offbeat pacing and quirky diction that
make up Anderson's signature dialogue
what do you think of a news as a person
I like but it's the element of his style
that's been strongest from the start and
it's present in all of his films one of
the clear markers of this style is an
over formalization of things that aren't
usually formalized and this scene from
Bottlerocket
and this one from Isle of Dogs a
formality and politeness is given to a
situation that wouldn't normally require
it before we attack each other and tear
ourselves to shreds like a pack of
maniacs let's just open the sack first
and see what's actually in it it might
not even be worth the trouble it was
there in Bottlerocket and west still
uses this framing device nine films
later for comedic effect I think it's
why filmmakers who attempt to emulate
parts of his visual style are often left
with something that feels empty and
superficial the stylistic core of a Wes
Anderson film is not actually the look
look is built on top of a stylized
approach to storytelling that starts in
the screenplay with the dialogue to
developing camerawork and layered action
what pans zooms and long tracking shots
are now fundamentals of Anderson's style
but you can see the foundation of his
interest in these techniques in
Bottlerocket
what do all of those have in common they
are all ways of using motion to develop
a shot many directors use developing
shots but for Wes what started as an
occasional use of the technique in
bottle rocket eventually developed into
a pillar of his style similarly we see
use of layers of action in bottle rocket
these become much more frequent and
pronounced throughout his filmography
[Music]
number three dialogue and motion okay
now we should also get on fitness regime
situps roadworks hitting the bags in ten
miles a day when I was out in the
desperate they thought like the producer
- Antonio coaches then you handle the
clinical side a this is another thing
that obviously isn't just unique to
Anderson but it would be strange to see
an Anderson film without it from the
very beginning Wes loves for his
characters to walk and talk number four
obsessive characters much of lesses
filmography seems to center around a
type of character that reoccurs again
and again in different forms in bottle
rocket we see the birth of the character
that is highly dedicated to something
that it's a little unusual to be highly
dedicated to max Fisher's obsession with
high school Steve Zissou obsession with
the aquatic life mr. Fox's obsession was
being abandoned Francis's obsession with
creating the perfect vacation for his
brothers Gustav H's obsession with
running a hotel
Scoutmaster Ward's obsession with being
a khaki scout Chaz's obsession was
safety all of these characters find
their seed indignance obsession with a
life of petty crime each of these
characters portray a level of formal
dedication to something that doesn't
usually require that kind of dedication
number five
portrayal of children I'm Anthony I'm
Grace's brother
another theme we catch a brief glimpse
of in bottle rocket that plays out in
more depth and Anderson's later films is
how he frames adult and child behavior
this films often feature adults behaving
like children and children displaying an
unusual level of maturity in the Royal
Tenenbaums this is perhaps the most
pronounced with the siblings acting like
mature adults as children but reverting
to childish behavior when they're older
number six portrayal of violence
Anderson's portrayal of violence or
force as ineffectual and kind of goofy
begins in bottle rocket in his films
violence isn't really made to look cool
the childish scuffle becomes more and
more abstracted throughout his
filmography
bonus round let's quickly touch on a few
of lesses smaller ideas and themes that
first appear in bottle rocket dear grace
I enjoyed your letter
I agree Camp Douglas isn't all it's
cracked up to be
Anthony's narration of his letter is an
early form of a technique Anderson will
use again and perhaps the only sign in
bottle rocket of the sort of meta
storytelling that Wes has become
increasingly interested in we've got
three jobs money isn't much involved in
particular isn't suited for this kind of
work please find enclosed dear Sam thank
you very much I got replaces the Raven
because I yelled at mrs. Lynn we see for
the first time Anderson's interest in
translation and language barrier for
storytelling and humor beautiful this
team won't be developed much in his
films until Isle of Dogs where it plays
a major role where somebody spoke his
language this scene where Anthony calls
around to find a Nez feels like an early
draft of the Society of keys sequence in
the grand Budapest hotel let's get lucky
and the drum line and use of handheld
camera in the robbery scene is used
again twice in the Royal Tenenbaums
[Music]
conclusion West Anderson has one of the
most identifiable visual styles and
because of this I think some of the most
interesting elements of his style often
get overlooked hopefully this video has
given you a look at some of the subtler
things that make a Wes Anderson film so
unique looking at a director's early
work and relationship to their later
work is a great exercise for learning
more about them let me know in the
comments what your favorite debut films
are I think I'll continue this as a
series where I look at a director's
first film and explore what it shows us
about their later work thanks to Mubi
for sponsoring this video I love using
Mubi and I'm excited to tell you guys
about it movie is a cinema streaming and
download service they hand curate their
selection there's only 30 movies at a
time one is added and one leaves every
day but you know those films will be
interesting and worth watching I use a
bunch of streaming services and
sometimes I get paralyzed by the sheer
amount of choice I've watched more films
on movie recently than anywhere else
because their hand curated catalog makes
it easier for me to decide what to watch
it's an always updating selection of
interesting cult classics forgotten gems
international and independent films so
give your scrolling some a break and try
something fresh
try movie free for 30 days at movie.com
slash thomas flight that's mu b.com
slash thomas flight for your extended
free trial
i'm thomas flight thanks so much for
watching big thank you to all my patreon
supporters and I'll talk to you again
soon